[Musique]
dia blanc
jour blanc comme on dit à man's man's
c'est quand la pluie persiste
et que la crue
comme si les habitants avaient encore
beau ben ça alors que le virus se
propage
il a fait de manaus la capitale mondiale
de l'épidémie de kobe 19 avec des tours
corps morbides
jusqu'à 200 décès par jour en janvier
[Musique]
voilà la file pour la vaccination
dans la seconde bac est bien pire que la
première
catastrophique à tous les niveaux depuis
45 silvio cavuscens
paul chevet des populations yanomami
d'amazonie
un peuple indigène fragile auquel ce
suisse originaire de genève a dédié son
ce matin il vient rendre visite à un
centre de soins installé en urgence par
les membres de la communauté dans la
banlieue de manaus tenu bon comment
quelles voies qu'avez vous
comme vous le voyez c'est un petit peu
d'improvisation
on va améliorer la saturation d'oxygène
avec un exercice allez il faut pousser
par la narine et lycées par la bouche
loco locass
mais les magpies quand
ça fait une semaine qu'elle est ici
elle a eu des antibiotiques mais on ne
peut pas la renvoyer chez elle car elle
a besoin d'oxygène
les yanomami et plus d'une trentaine
d'autres et qui sont venus s'installer
sur cette terre en lisière de la ville
pour trouver du travail des populations
vulnérables et souvent délaissée nikkei
as 25 ans est le chef du quartier il a
pris la relève de son père il est mort
du virus il ya quelques mois ils sont
venus ici
envoyé à l'hôpital car là bas
vont mourir
tu vois il n'y a plus rien ça ne bouge
plus même quand j'ouvre plus d'oxygène
ils pensaient qu'ils avaient encore une
réserve d'oxygène de fait ils n'ont pas
de réserves alors en fait ces cylindres
maintenant sont les derniers qui avaient
cette dramatique mais c'est dramatique
de toute la région en fait c'est pour
les peuples indigènes les populations
traditionnelles les cas boucle de
l'intérieur de l'amazonie qui se
trouvent toutes dans cette situation la
chance ici c'est encore un quartier
périphérique comme tu sors de manaus tu
te trouve tout de suite d'un situation
d'abandon le plus total difficultés de
communication difficultés de transport
et puis pas de soins
quand ils habitent hors de leurs terres
traditionnelles
les indigènes perdent leur statut
coutumier aux yeux de l'état
les gens doivent savoir ce qui se passe
rien qu'aujourd'hui nous avons 16 cas
positifs à l'orée des villes beaucoup se
retrouvent marginalisés
c'est ce que dénonce me callas sur les
réseaux sociaux en espérant faire réagir
les plus hautes autorités du pays
[Musique]
une étude publiée dans la revue science
prétendait que la ville avait atteint
l'immunité collective en octobre dernier
pourtant depuis quelques semaines elle
fait face à la résurgence affolante de
nouveaux pains
il serait lié à l'apparition d'un
variante amazonian
puissant du contagieux difficile encore
de le dire mais ils sèment le chaos dans
les hôpitaux et pour geler familles de
victimes dans le désert
on a perdu ma belle-mère il ya cent les
jours
on a enterré un proche un autre jour
elle ment c'est mon père qui tourne à
l'hôpital
[Musique]
et potentiellement voile enterré lui
aussi c'est ça la situation
saturé de patients les hôpitaux on
appelle dans l'état absent
alors on se tourne vers dieu
ce pasteur vient tous les matins devant
l'hôpital pour prier avec les siens
prions pour celle qui est alité mon dieu
souffle le vent de la veille sur elle
au nom de jésus de nuit la porte se
rétablira par la volonté d saint-esprit
90 % des infections de la deuxième vague
loutété par le nouveau variant
de quoi inquiéter encore plus silvio
cette fois il est venu prendre des
nouvelles auprès d'une amie infirmière
et elles ne sont pas bonnes je vois les
gens à mourir et je perds des collègues
des voisins on dirait que c'est de pire
en pire tu en penses quoi
est ce que l'on sait c'est que ce
nouveau variant est plus les talents et
le problème c'est que les gens ne
respectent pas assez les recommandations
des autorités sanitaires
regarde cette vidéo ce jour là c'était
le chaos
c'était ou dans notre unité
quand les réserves d'oxygène ont été
terminés les proches on allait chercher
des cylindres d'oxygène eux-mêmes pour
essayer de sauver ce qui était
hospitalisé
regarde
et là je me suis senti mal et j'en ai la
chair de poule
je me suis sentie tellement
c'était horrible
je vais rien faire
[Musique]
juste avant noël
ça n'a pas marché il ya l'humain
prestation des commerçants de la ville
etc maintenant tout le monde on paye les
conséquences
manque de politiques publiques adéquates
la population n'a pas joué le jeu non
plus
avec son amie lola si l'on se rend vers
un autre quartier indigènes où le virus
s'est répandu
contaminants certains habitants pour la
deuxième fois
[Musique]
bonjour comment allez vous doubin
j'ai encore beaucoup beaucoup de fièvre
parfois je me réveille en tremblant
j'ai encore mal à la tête mal au ventre
je suis et glisse
comme on marieront du travail je n'ai
même sous la forme de les faire un café
encore des médicaments
oui et des infusions d'herbe
traditionnel aussi
et dans toutes ces villes par exemple
dans la vie dans le village d'où vient
ce goût là il ya plus de 900 indigènes
qui vivent dans une petite ville atalay
du nord sur la frontière du brésil avec
le pérou et bien ils sont cent sont si
les autres de la population de la
municipalité
n'ont déjà pas imagine les indigènes qui
viennent des terres de l'intérieur de
loin ils viennent des sources de la
vesle du javari à plus de mille
kilomètres du siège de la municipalité
alors non pas d'ipad il n'ya pas
d'attention de base il n'ya pas les
soins nécessaires et c'est chacun pour
soi
chacun pour soi ou quand les médicaments
font défaut revenir aux méthodes
traditionnelles
ça par exemple c'est de la cannelle ça
aide à tranquilliser les patients qui
sont dans un état grave
des remèdes à base de plantes
médicinales pour soulager ou renforcer
les défenses immunitaires
les yanomami n'ont rien perdu du savoir
faire de leurs ancêtres ni de la
solidarité face à l'adversité dans ses
cartons du matériel tri génique que les
associations espèrent expédié dans
quelques jours vers des villages isolés
en amont du fleuve
silvio et je me suis rappelé que j'ai
aussi ses masques que tu peux envoyer au
chef
c'est important car quand qu'ils vont en
ville souvent eu non pas de masque
et on a aussi le kit d'hygiène buccale
pour les enfants
très bien on va les distribuer au
village merci beaucoup
notre père c'est que le virus touche les
peuples dont il ne reste plus de
quelques membres
sinner c'est toute une ligne t7 à
cette solidarité entre les peuples les
associations dans différentes régions et
puis 7 cette amitié cette amitié qui
unit les peuples ils sont tous d'un même
bateau ils ont toujours un problème ils
affrontent eux mêmes les fuir
[Musique]
sur le riz aux quelques rares
bateaux assure une liaison vitale avec
les autres communautés installées sur
les rives du fleuve
en temps normal silvio fait le voyage
mais depuis que la pandémie s'est
déclarée il se l'interdît par peur
d'amener le virus au coeur de
populations qui n'ont jamais eu de
contact avec l'extérieur avant que le
contact produisent avec les peuples
indigènes amazoniens
ces peuples étaient parfaitement
capables de subvenir à leur besoin de
répondre à leurs soucis de santé le
contact amené beaucoup de mots amener
des maladies des virus du syndrome qui
ne connaissaient pas et face auxquels
ils ont énormément souffert ses preuves
que se transformant rapidement de mounir
est un enfant jusqu'à l'âge de 5 ans et
d'une telle facilité qu'ont
quelques jours il faut mourir
hélas passion que le taux de mortalité
infantile entre les peuples indigènes
est cinq fois plus élevé que la
population normale
ça commence à me manquer sérieusement
nos amis
ok mais on est dans une sacrée histoire
avec eux on essaie de construire quelque
chose avec eux c'est vrai que
ça nous montre les réunions les
assemblées discuter des stratégies avec
eux chercher des solutions est depuis
hier construire le futur de son peuple
[Musique]
rester à quai il en va de la survie des
26000 yanomami recensés à ce jour
et des dizaines d'autres ethnies qui
forment les communautés indigènes
d'amazonie
oh